I feel like this tournament has a lot of
history for me and I put too much
pressure on myself so this year I just
want to get to determine without
worrying about how's this person doing
like how this is gonna change my
tournament oh I didn't win a game but
does this mean for me it just really
take one game at a time and I know I say
this every year to myself and everything
but this year that's my only focus it's
just one game at a time and not worry
about anything else
last year I was actually I did pretty
good I think like I was really close to
top 3 I think maybe top there would be a
good felt disarmament okay I want to say
that and imply terrible so I really want
to be in top 5 but I think I'll know a
little more as I go along the way
playing really good chest trying to play
my best definitely not any of the game
sloppy or anything about everything to
like be best in the tournament and yeah
I'm trying to win as many games as
possible I want to get better I want to
make my rating go up I just want to have
like a solid tournament and as well as I
possibly can if I don't do that I mean
let's look hey at least I got the
experience from the turn of it but I
really I really would like to do well I
just wanna do better than I did the
first time yeah just improve a bit this
is slightly like you feel for us some
new faces and I'm very excited and
usually us championship it's a lot of
pressure for me and for an arena like
everyone expect us like me arena win
like everyone know I just want to have a
good tournament show my better play and
be just prepared to deal with the
inevitable ups and downs are gonna
happen here I think I have to be ready
for that you know I'm not I think at the
point where you know it's possible to
score some kind of dominating score with
like no hiccups along the way those
years are gone last five years I didn't
play my chest like there were a few
games and very few tournaments in a year
and I just started to a plane and I hope
this it will help me to play better like
this year we'll try to enjoy chess and
I'm most thinking about results I'm
certainly coming in as the US Champion
but I'm also 8th seed at this point
based on the rating so it has to be one
one game taken at a time and we'll see
what will happen I don't feel any
pressure so